I'm just gonna run through this very
exciting stuff we're in the presence of
how many times
yeah that's why all of my religious
icons are all back here watching over
asses we praise you today except for
this one this one someone caught Jesus
in a derp face actually he's rolling his
eyes like come on are you excited to be
here um that's a leading question
meaning that you should answer in a
positive way
I am NOT not excited okay I don't know
my tumblr to ask you guys to send me the
worst comments you could find on its
face videos and today Nick is going to
praise the lovely humans who let those
comments Betty okay I read back students
please die your hair back please grace
just please the brown makes me not like
your videos and makes your face look fat
I'm sorry just this really bothers me
I'm serious for your life it's better to
go back to your old color without
knowing her background I mean just by
knowing her name I ran best students hmm
she's not an anonymous user she's
somebody who's willing to put her name
out there and say hey listen I'm a fan
and I happen to know a little more on
the subject than you do if somebody who
supports you and wants to kid you
watching your videos which I can't right
now physically I can't watch the videos
here's a tip go here back and I I see a
lot of love enough messaging the balls I
don't understand this new YouTube genre
of weird a BD random pointless spots
edited
to a video it's honestly very disturbing
to me how anyone can find this
entertaining or industry interesting
mm-hmm the balls the guys obviously got
some big balls I don't understand it
either and I don't think it's for us to
understand I think that he's coming to
terms with that and he's using this
public forum to reach out and say hey
tell me if I'm wrong well 82 I took that
as a compliment yeah yeah I can't focus
on things I'm sorry it's because I think
everything is so important it's hard for
me just to kind of settle on one thing
exactly and we're supporting the
pharmaceutical companies mm-hmm with our
ATV and the adderall is actually this is
a great time to call on our sponsor
advil thank you thank you
full metal fan for life the most
annoying what's on YouTube to me that
comment which is one more time
holy SH one of the most annoying on
YouTube do we do we know location is he
British that think in Britain that the
word dislike appraised it is it's a
compliment I don't know if annoying is a
praise over there or not either I think
we got a British guy is telling you that
you just thank you full metal fan for
life and I mean the only negative here
is that he considers me one of the most
and not in the most yeah sad like to see
is list and I'd like to argue with the
rest of them so the other tough thing
for me is if they're no one's liked the
comment I think that
one that you think would have just kind
of flown up yeah what's out there but
it's probably a lot of Americans reading
and not knowing that it's a British guy
saying that yeah you're one of the best
more great if he truly is a Snow Leopard
and you were able to use a keyboard and
spell over these words correctly
congratulations
where did you get into next that's I
mean I got a lot of questions yeah
whatever
DC why does she have 1 million cells I
don't get it is vagina and diary image
jokes the pinnacle of comedy now Wow
someone's standing here at the pinnacle
of comedy I guess so I mean yeah that's
what it sounds like to me I've talked
about vaginas and diarrhea people are
saying yeah she's are the pinnacle I
feel like full metal fan for life
definitely it was one of the thumbs up
on this yeah they're two neighbors I
mean they're right next story of each
other they know each other they share a
wall hopefully they never actually meet
Hanahan but yeah I'm sure every now and
again there's some backlash wanna say
that we would have never even brought up
the vagina and or diarrhea probably in
this video if they didn't encourage us
to and thank you for your encouragement
we would have forgotten and we would
have looked terrible egg on our face we
don't like not at the pinnacle getting
distracted by all the kids coming out of
school I love that yeah well that makes
you seem a little creepy well I support
the truancy laws there's a cafe across
the street that as opposed to truancy
laws and if you see a kid around
what times right now it is yeah do you
see a kid before to out you're supposed
to recall school reported truancy and
the whole neighborhood supporting that
so I'm kind of I'm kind of you know I
could consider myself a monitor all I
wanted to ever
my life is citizen's arrest someone you
know that it's actually illegal and I
found that out the hard way I don't know
you want to know another great bathroom
oh yeah any notes for bathroom oh you
can actually in rich people don't want
to read this thing you know where you
can like they have this like the thing
you can return anything Norman they'll
take it but also their bathroom laws are
insane you can poop in sink or in
urinals make there has been here to give
you life advice if you go use a
Nordstrom take a picture and put it on
Instagram and tag Nick and I thank you
so much for being here and for
complimenting all of the wonderful
wonderful viewers out there you're
they're doing arrived can I give them a
quick message yeah you are important and
your life isn't meaningless you're doing
the right thing what you're saying is
being heard and it matters and it's what
it's inspiring us and if sorry but it is
inspiring us Janice and I area thank you
where can they find you on social media
you guys can find me on an app I would
remind the comments these people are
leaving about videos this is like the
olden days when people would go in and
see the Mona any Monet painting or any
like Picasso and they had the piece of
paper any other people could say I've
seen this yellow before yeah or this is
absolute crap this is following a
tradition of what our forefathers did
yeah so anyway you can find me you can
see my special on Netflix Nick's tuneful
Kuro it's also on iTunes or spawning can
we trim back the beard yeah I embrace
man you know I realized that it's a
thing out there that people are aware of
yeah I know some people need it for
their professions and you just clap
tonight
completely you're hearing that too right
at first I thought I was going to play
it off like she won't notice my comment
yeah the only human in this entire
office ability